[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEVEN SONEFF: All
right, so today we're
going to be talking about
something that's not
quite directly perf-related.
If you were at Colt's
keynote earlier this morning,
and you could understand
what he was saying,
he said, yes, perf matters.
And perf does matter.
But it doesn't
matter quite so much
if you can't get the
user you need signed in,
or signed up to the app
that you're building.
So that's what
we're going to talk
about today is how you can
get users signed up or signed
into your apps a lot
more easily by using
a variety of different
technologies on Android,
and ones that are
provided by Google.
So just to give you a little
bit of an introduction,
my name is Steven.
I work on the identity
team at Google.
And identity at Google
is really about knowing
who the user is-- so
knowing that it's them
when they come to
see their Gmail,
and that it's not the bad guys.
Keep the bad guys out.
And over the years,
we've been thinking
a lot about how to get
the Google user signed in.
But in doing that, and keeping
all of those Google users
secure, we've come up with
a pretty strong account
system that could be very useful
to the third party ecosystem,
to all of the app
developers that
are out there who are
thinking about how
to get their users
signed in or signed up.
And it's probably
a problem that you
might have encountered yourself,
if you're building an app.
I certainly-- before
coming to Google,
I actually worked at
a bunch of startups.
And this is, I think, one of
the fundamental problems--
that if you need to have
some kind of account
system for your users
to be able to keep track
of their information, to be able
to personalize content to them,
you need to know who they are.
And it can be a real barrier to
actually have somebody sign up
or sign into a service.
It's something where you
could have-- in fact,
a lot of the apps that we
work with have seen that,
in the order of 50% of the
people who see their login
screen, just take off or fail
to login in the first place.
And so that is really
a major problem,
if 50% of the
potential people who
are using your app
or your service
are going to evaporate
right away before they even
get in the door.
So thinking about
that, and putting it
in the perspective of
all these things you
have to think
about-- performance,
and getting users
into your apps,
making sure that is as
frictionless as possible,
is really one of the key ones
that you have to keep in mind.
And so that's what we're
going to talk about here.
Some of the solutions
that you've probably
heard about before are
things like Google Sign-in.
If you've wandered
around the web,
you see these Google Sign-in
buttons all over the place.
And it is a really
nice solution.
It certainly gives you the
ability to log in with a click,
without having to create
more usernames and passwords.
It's kind of the opportunity to
replace some of these password
logins that you've
maybe used in the past.
But it's not the
complete solution,
in that there are still apps
and sites out there that
use passwords and
usernames, and we
have to think about
what to do there.
And that's one of the
new technologies that I'd
like to talk about today,
which is this concept of Smart
Lock for Passwords, or an
API to save login information
that users have collected
in the past through Chrome,
through the Password
Manager there, and be
able to make it available
programmatically on Android.
So very cool, and I think it's
one of the most exciting things
that we've seen in
the authentication
space in a long time.
So just to get into what
I'll cover today and give you
the quick overview,
there's Google Sign-in.
And I'll give you a
little bit of an update
of what we're doing there.
But basically, Google Sign-in
is this cross-platform solution.
It works on iOS and
Android and on the web--
that it makes signing
in or signing up really
easy, that it enables access
to lot of other Google APIs,
so very useful
there, and that it
can facilitate some
nice things, like being
able to download an associated
app from your website.
So that's been
around for awhile.
And I use this analogy of
comparing the Google Sign-in--
which is like a replacement for
the different keys you may be
use to log in to
different services
around the web-- you can
imagine going from site to site
and each one presents a door
that you have to unlock.
You have to have
a different key.
And over time, you accumulate
a lot of these keys.
They get pretty
heavy in your pocket.
And you end up in
this situation where
it's nice to have
a Google Sign-in,
but you still have a lot in
your pocket to worry about.
And to complete
the analogy, then,
the idea behind a Smart
Lock for Passwords
is that you can
put all these keys
on a keychain-- kind of in
the same idea as a password
manager.
But by making it a
programmatic interface,
we can do a lot more.
That we can build
user interfaces
that don't even involve
a sign-in screen anymore,
if you can programmatically
pull login information up
for a given user.
So that's one of the
really exciting pieces.
And I'll show you some pieces of
the UI, and what it looks like,
and how you can integrate
it in your app, too.
But in short, it's a
cross-platform, single sign-in
solution, working on
Android right now,
and there's APIs in the beta
channel for Chrome, as well.
Save and retrieve that
login information,
could be username and
passwords, but also,
more generally,
as an API, in fact
saving other kinds of
login-- whether a user signed
in with Google, or with
Facebook, or Twitter.
And making that all available
the next time they come back,
so that they don't
even have to think
about the new problem
that has been introduced
by all these other different
ways to login, which
is to remember which
button was clicked,
let alone what the username
or the password was,
and how to link all
of those together.
Those are really being addressed
by this more broad solution
in Smart Lock for Passwords.
We've had quite a bit
of luck, actually,
with getting partners on
board with this Smart Lock
for Passwords set of APIs.
You can see some icons
of a few noteworthy ones
we launched with
earlier this year--
Netflix, the "New York
Times," LinkedIn coming soon,
Orbitz, Eventbrite-- which
you might have even used
if you had your tickets
through Eventbrite today,
and Instacart.
But before we get into the
Smart Lock for Passwords,
I just wanted to talk
a little bit about what
the latest on Sign-in is.
So Google Sign-in-- or in the
past what you probably had
seen, or had maybe
implemented in your own app,
is Google+ Sign-in-- so this
has really been changing over
the last few months, that you
no longer need a Google+ account
for many things at Google,
and that includes signing in.
So if you have used the
API in the last few months,
since we've updated
it on Android, on iOS,
and on the web, you'll see that
the default set of things that
your Google Sign-in
implementation asks for, no
longer includes
Google+ information.
It's what we call the basic
set of profile scopes.
So that's things like email,
information about the user's
name, and profile picture.
And with that more basic set of
information, you can brand it.
And by default, it's now branded
just with the plain Google
logo, the new one
with the colors
that we put out there
just last month.
And really a much cleaner
experience for the end user.
I'll show you exactly what
it looks like in a sec.
But the general
idea here, again,
is that this is the gateway
to all of Google's APIs,
that it's not just
knowing who the user is
on Google-- the name and the
email address-- but, in fact,
having access to things
like their contacts,
being able to pull messages
out of their Gmail,
store things in Drive,
upload to YouTube,
anything you can imagine--
payment information,
and a lot of other
really useful stuff.
So not just the
authentication piece, but also
the authorization piece.
But in talking about that, we
should really see what the UI
looks like now in this
streamlined model,
where if you've used a
Google+ Sign-in in the past,
you might have seen
some of these--
the older APIs on Android
look like that first screen,
which harks back to the old days
of Android with the holo theme.
That's on the way out
with the material world
these days, the
new API on Android.
I should actually mention that
this new API is rolling out
right now, so if you're looking
to build it into your app,
wait for the next
Play Services update.
It will be in there.
And with it, you get
this very nice UI.
So just to say that this is
like a one tap experience now.
If you click on the plain
Google Sign-in button,
you'll get a picker
for which account
you want to sign in with.
So that's the basic profile
set of information, very clean,
one tap.
And it replaces a lot of what
users had some frustration
or road bumps in
the process before,
which is things like
the ugly picker,
having to create a Google+
account if they didn't have one
already.
And then the wall of text
around getting access
to circles, information,
things like that,
that for a lot of apps, in
reality, didn't end up using.
So a barrier to getting into
your app quickly and easily.
And so that's one
of the big pieces
that have been addressed here.
And certainly, if you are
an Android developer who's
put this into your app, do
take a look at the latest APIs
as they come out,
because you'll have
this much streamlined
experience.
And then you can also
then, what we say,
incrementally ask for additional
scopes, additional permissions
to access the
user's Google data--
things like contacts and so on.
And be able to do
it then in context.
So one tap to sign in,
and then at the time
you need to, access contact
information to send messages,
for example, you can
do it then, and have
the user understand what that
is actually being used for.
So really aligning nicely
with the device level
permissions that you
might be seeing in Android
with the Marshmallow release.
So that's the latest on
Sign-in, so watch out
for that one coming in the
next couple weeks on Android.
But to get into the Smart Lock
for Passwords side of things--
so I mentioned this earlier,
but basically using something
like a Google Sign-in,
is this opportunity
to replace the
password-- so have
a super key that you
can use across the doors
that you encounter on the web.
And no longer have to
remember these passwords,
or come up with new ones for
the sites that you encounter.
But again, like I
said, not everyone
uses the Google Sign-in, or
Facebook, or Twitter sign-in.
There's still a lot
of people out there
who, for whatever
reason, choose or prefer
to log in with
passwords, and there
are a lot of sites that
still use passwords
for whatever legacy reason.
They've been around
for a long time
and they have
established user bases.
They just prefer having their
own proprietary login system
with their own
username and passwords.
And that does
present a problem--
if you've got that heavy
pocket full of keys,
then you might think about
ways to lighten the load.
That if you just went out
there and used one key
across all the doors that
you came across, then
you'd only have that
one to worry about.
Or if you used a really
simple, light one that's
easy to remember,
an easy password,
it can certainly
lighten your pocket.
But it can also introduce
a pretty major security
vulnerability, which is that if
that one key that you rely on
gets stolen, gets picked
out of your pocket,
then people can basically
walk through all of the doors
that you would encounter.
And if that key is
really light and simple,
easy to counterfeit, you
have the same problem.
So thinking about how
to encourage people
to move to stronger passwords,
make them easier to use,
and then eventually move to
ways to move beyond passwords
is really where we're trying
to get the industry to go.
And by providing these
APIs to the third party
ecosystem on Android, we hope
to make that a lot easier.
So let me get into Smart
Lock for Passwords.
And again, I'll just motivate it
by saying that this is probably
one of the things that,
as an app developer,
you're really conscious of--
that there's a lot of time
and effort and energy
that goes into marketing
the apps or the services
that you're building,
to make people aware of what
it is that you're offering
to them, and to get
them to download
the app can be a pretty
expensive and time-consuming
process.
And that's just the
beginning, then.
You have to get them to
open it, to get engaged.
And that means, potentially,
signing up for an account,
or signing in.
And that can be a very,
very friction-full process.
That as soon as
people see that screen
where they have to create
yet another account,
like I said earlier in the
apps that we've worked with,
there's often 50% or
more bounce rate there,
that those users are
evaporating right off the bat.
So much for all the marketing
and the download effort
that went into that user.
And that even if
they do sign in,
it's very often the case that
it wasn't the first attempt that
succeeded-- that there was
a wrong password in there,
that you picked on
a different provider
and it's asking you
to link accounts or do
something really confusing.
All problematic.
And I think the
opportunity here is
that, to get to that
bottom of the funnel,
to get the really
engaged user, you
can use something
like Smart Lock
to make it completely seamless.
So to get rid of this
conversion killer,
and just to make it clear
how this works as an API,
I'll walk through a bit of
an example with some UI.
But just to give you
the architecture here.
Like I mentioned earlier,
one way to think about it
is that there are
users who have probably
been using Chrome for years,
and stored a lot of their login
information.
I have a lot of my information
in the cloud in this way.
Basically stored with
their Google accounts
all the passwords they've gone
and entered to different sites
that they've come
across on the web.
And a lot of that
information is very
valuable-- it would be great
if you could access that
on Android in a native
app, your associated app,
with your website.
And that's what is made
possible here by these APIs
that we're calling
part of the Smart Lock
suite of technologies,
to basically make
sign-in and authentication
wherever you go really easy.
So it's all backed by this
cloud, Google account stored
information, login
information, like passwords.
And let's see how
it works in an app,
like a publisher
app, for example,
in the "New York Times."
So "New York Times"
launched with us.
And you can imagine a scenario
like this-- you are a "New York
Times" reader.
You've set up on your
phone, for example,
a subscription to
the "New York Times,"
entered your payment
information, all of [INAUDIBLE]
a really invested user, and
you've put a lot of effort
into setting up this
account on your phone.
Now, the problem is that maybe
you have a second device,
or you buy a tablet,
something like that-- and now
you open up the "New
York Times" app,
and it shows you the
login screen yet again.
And it could very well
have been the case
that you set up that "New York
Times" account a long time ago,
that it could've
been a year ago.
Now you have no idea what
email address you used,
what the password was.
And then it's a very,
very painful experience
of recovering that.
For the "New York
Times," they have
to provide support to all of
these users, who are their paid
customers, to be able to get
back into their accounts.
So that's really an opportunity.
And so if you think about this
new device, or second device,
you can imagine that
we've done a lot of work
to get that device
bootstrapped--
to get all of the
apps and the services
that you were previously using
on Android available right
there.
We call this the Tap
and Go setup experience,
where all of the
apps are put back
onto the new device-- they're
even in the same place.
But again, this fundamental
problem of opening that app
and seeing that
it's not signed in.
So now, look what the experience
is with this API integration.
As soon as that "New York
Times," app is opened,
there's a notification
here to the user--
this is a first run experience.
The text is a little bit hard
to read on the screen here,
but basically what
it's saying is
that you've been signed
back in automatically
with information that
you've saved with Google.
So the last time you used
this on an Android device,
you opted in to save whatever
login information that you
input, and now it's been
retrieved programmatically
by the app.
The app is able to look at
what kind of login information
is available for
this user, and then
be able to basically use it
to skip the login screen.
So just think about
that for a second--
that it's not just
the experience
that you've seen in
Chrome, where your username
and password is filled
in, and the user still
has to find the login page.
It's that this user
just opens up the app,
and they're in, just like that.
And then of course, being
the cross-platform solution,
you can think about
other scenarios
where this is really powerful.
So let's use Eventbrite
for a second example.
And like I said
earlier, Eventbrite
was one of the ticketing
apps I think for this event,
and probably for a lot of
others that you may encounter.
And maybe this time you start
on the web, where you actually
made the purchase of tickets,
or something like that.
And you could very well
have been an Eventbrite user
for a long time in Chrome,
and over the years, come
to save passwords for
sites like Eventbrite
in the Chrome Password Manager.
And if you've
signed into Chrome,
then you've basically synced
all of this information
up to the cloud.
You've saved it with
your Google account.
And if you go to another
device with Chrome,
it'll very helpfully
fill it in for you.
But of course, you
end up in an app.
And so maybe you're
in the line here,
and you need to
show your ticket.
Everybody's waiting behind you.
And if you open up
the app and realize
that you need to log
in to get that ticket,
it can be pretty stressful to
type that in with your thumbs
while everyone's waiting,
and hope that you've
got the right password.
So the experience
now, if you just
open up the app with
this integration in it--
and you can try
this out yourself.
You might already be
signed into Eventbrite,
but if you uninstall
and reinstall it,
you can actually see how it will
just sign you in automatically.
It will give you this
blue bar at the bottom.
It says your login information.
And from that point
on, again, you've
basically just skipped
the entire login flow.
And as an app
developer, you can think
about how valuable
this is, that you
can skip all of the warm
welcomes and the things
that are just getting in the way
of your really engaged and most
valuable users getting
to their content.
OK, so that's Eventbrite.
And let's walk through
maybe one more example.
So think about moving
in the other direction,
and thinking about some of
the other powerful things
that this API can do.
So suppose we're setting up
your flights or your travel
information to the
Big Android BBQ.
And in order to do
that, you had to,
of course, go to
a travel website,
and probably look up
some flight information,
plan an itinerary,
that kind of thing.
One of the big ones out there
that I like using is Orbitz,
and we've got them on board
with this API, as well.
And the idea here,
then, is that you
could start all of
your travel planning,
do all of your
research on mobile--
on a phone or a tablet.
And then you can
save it and use it
in Chrome or on other platforms.
But there's more
to it than that.
With this API, it's
actually pretty
powerful in that there's more
than just the save and retrieve
API.
There's another one
that we provide,
also coming out in the
update in a week or two,
the version that's
rolling out right now.
It's basically this ability
to help the user sign up
in the first place.
And so how this
works is basically
if the person has saved their
login information for a variety
of different apps and sites, and
they've got a Google account,
then we know some
information about them.
We know which email addresses
they use, the different ways
that they log in.
And we can present
to the end user
basically this dialogue at the
time that they need to sign it.
You can have them pick--
if your system is based
on email addresses or on
phone numbers-- basically
have them pick the information
that they need to sign in with.
So the email address
that they would prefer.
And the nice thing
about this, if you've
been working with M or
permissions on Marshmallow,
is that this dialog calling
into the Play Services
doesn't actually require
any device permissions.
So now you've got
something very, very useful
here, that you don't need
to ask for or get accounts,
or don't need to ask for phone
number permission anymore.
You can have the user give you
that information by calling
into a Play Services API.
So they pick that email address.
And then, in fact, if
you think about some
of the optimizations to
your app that you could do,
you could actually put the
user into the right flow,
if they're an
existing user, know
that they need to
sign back in, know
how they should be logging
in for that email address,
for example.
Or you can intelligently put
them into a sign-up flow.
So in the case of this
example, let's say
that we'll just do an account
creation here, or sign
into an existing account.
So we have to put in the
username and password.
So let's just suppose
it's a password account.
But that said, you
could do very well
the same thing for the other
different types of login.
That if the user were to sign in
with Google, or with Facebook,
you have that
opportunity, once they've
entered this information, to
save that pointer, basically,
that it was a Facebook
or a Google sign in,
and that's what you should
trigger the next time.
So we'll take a look at
how that looks in a sec.
But basically, at the
point that they've
entered this information,
they get a prompt that says,
would you like to save the
password that you've entered?
This is the opt-in
to basically store
the information with Google.
It's very similar in
functionality to what you've
probably seen in Chrome, where
there's a bubble that pops up
and there's a save
and no thanks.
Same idea here, that they opt
in to save that information
to the Google account.
And then once it's stored in
the cloud, then it's available.
It's synced across all
the different platforms.
It's synced to Chrome.
And then in fact,
if you go to Chrome,
you can see that
information filled in.
So you can try this out
yourself in the Orbitz app.
It's live along with the other
partners, basically the ability
to go from one
platform to the other,
have that information fill
in using the existing Chrome
Password Manager.
But in fact, there's
even better stuff coming,
that in the Chrome
beta channel right now,
we've been working
with a community
to basically put a
spec out there, a web
spec, that enables password
management, or credential
management, more generally,
as a programmatic API
in the browser.
So if you read up on the
spec, navigator.credentials,
you can check for
availability of that API
in the browser you're using
coming to Chrome pretty soon.
And basically, if
that API is available,
then you can do the same
programmatic functionality
that I've described on
Android in the browser.
So imagine going
from your Android app
to the Chrome on
the same device,
and having those two
in sync, because you
know the user in both places.
Or going to another
device altogether,
where this person
potentially has never
visited your site before,
but since the Google
account is there, you can
do an automatic sign-in.
So they could show up through
search results, something
like that, and have a
completely seamless experience.
And that really highlights
one of the values
here that I think makes
this interesting to Google,
and to the ecosystem as a
whole-- is that this just
enables the end user who
doesn't even really understand
the concept of saving credential
information, or how it works,
and just give them this
seamless experience
as they go across the web.
Whether they're coming
through search results
or they're going to your website
directly, their state is there,
and they're put into
the place that they
need to be-- pick up
right where they left off,
and the ability to
re-engage and give them
the best experience possible.
So that's an overview of
how basically the UI works,
and how it looks in apps that
you might see out there right
now.
In fact, I just
looked up this morning
who's using the API right now.
And I already showed you
some examples of big ones
like Netflix, with their
TV app coming out as well,
the idea that you can sign
in on Android or Chrome
and be signed in on
Android TV, as well.
So that's pretty cool.
And "Times," and Eventbrite,
Orbitz, Instacart,
other-- but some nice big ones
that have launched recently
are TripAdvisor, Overstock,
Fancy, Gold Star--
another ticketing app--
and some big ones coming
soon like LinkedIn,
TuneIn, Evernote, Groupon,
Ticketmaster.
And lots more
internationally, too-- ones
like eBay's properties around
the world, all of these apps
and sites basically
leveraging this opportunity
to keep their user signed in.
So let me talk a little
bit about what you actually
need to do to put this
into the app or the site
that you're building.
So I'll focus on
the Android side
today, since we're at an
Android developer conference.
And if you'd like to
find out more about this,
we're going to run
a codelab tomorrow.
So in fact, what I'll
show you in a sec
here is that it's pretty simple.
It's just a couple of API calls.
And you could probably
come to the session
tomorrow, and get it
implemented in your app.
So if there's anything that you
take away from the conference,
this might be a good one.
You can get this very high ROI,
like very, very big improvement
to the login flow
of your app by just
adding a few lines of code.
So the first thing you need
is Play Services, the latest
version.
So many of you probably
already have Play Services
in your app-- probably
wouldn't be too big
an issue to move over
to the latest version.
And then from
there, basically how
it works is when the app
starts, you call into the API
and you say, hey, are
there any credentials
saved for the current
users on this device?
And so, of course, this is
backed by the Google account.
And on Android, the
vast majority of people
are signed in with
the Google account.
They have the ability to
store this information.
And in fact, if they've already
saved something in Chrome,
it could very well be the
case that even if you're
launching this integration
in your Android app
anew, that they already have
something saved from Chrome.
We've seen in the order of 10%
to 15% just right off the bat
get an automatic
sign-in experience.
So that's pretty cool.
So what you do is
you call request,
you wait for a callback, and
then you look at the result.
And the result could be a
couple different scenarios here,
that I'll walk through.
There's either exactly
one credential available,
and this is the auto
sign-in scenario.
The idea being that you get
a successful result back,
you look inside and see what
kind of credential it was.
I mentioned earlier that it
could very well be the case
that it's not just a
username password credential,
it could the fact
that they've signed
in with Google or Facebook.
The token for those
kind of sign-ins
isn't actually stored in the
API, it's just a pointer.
It says ah, this user signed
in with Facebook last time,
you should trigger
the Facebook flow
and make sure to have Facebook
validate, or Google validate,
or Twitter validate that this
is the same user as before.
So that's the kind of scenario
for a so-called federated
or identity provider login.
But then, of course,
there's still
the scenario where this person
logged in with a password.
And then you simply
get the password back,
and you can imagine
the experience
for an automatic
sign-in is basically
filling out the fields for
them, and tapping the button.
But the nice thing there
is that you don't even
need to show them that
UI-- you can hide this
behind the splash
screen of your app.
And all they see is
the nice blue bar
on top of the splash screen.
And then the next
view that they've
got after that is the
signed-in state-- picking up
wherever they left off
from the last session
or the last device.
So you do have to think about
a couple of corner cases.
So one of the common
ones is if someone
has multiple credentials saved.
For example, this could
be a shared device,
where you have
multiple people signed
in-- they've saved information
to different accounts.
And the idea here
is that we need
to have some disambiguation.
That the person who's
seeing this screen,
the login experience,
is that they'll actually
have to pick between the
two or more credentials.
It's also the scenario that
if they, for their accountant,
have disabled automatic sign-in,
one of the Google settings
there-- not the
default, but there
are a few people who want to
have that level of control,
which is nice-- be able
to pick the credential
that they want to sign in with.
And to detect that in
the code you write,
you basically just
check for this state,
resolution required.
And the result
that you get back,
if it's resolution
required, then
you can fire off an intent
at whatever point in your UI
fits in.
And then the idea is that
you'll be called back
when the user picks one
of the saved credentials.
Or they could very well cancel,
and create a new account,
something like that.
So then, under the
scenario that there's
nothing saved in
the API, you have
to think-- going back
to that Orbitz example
that we talked about--
that what do you
do if there's nothing saved?
And a nice thing here
is that this is just
an API on top of whatever
you've already built.
So basically you could very well
just operate in the scenario
that this API were not there.
That the user's going to have
to manually select or input
their login information.
And this works out
perfectly well.
It's certainly not
a loss of anything
that you currently had.
But now you've got a couple
of opportunities here.
One is that you can
check it in the state,
that if it's valuable, you
can use that picker I showed
earlier-- that you can have
them tap, with one action,
the identifier that they need,
the email address, or the phone
number, and use that to
bootstrap the sign-in process.
Or you could just use
the existing flow.
And if you go through
the existing flow,
then you have the
opportunity, after they've
entered login
information, and you've
validated that it's correct,
you have the opportunity
to present them with that save
dialogue we showed earlier.
And then once this
information is saved,
then next time they
come back, they'll
be able to do the
automatic sign-in.
And in fact, like I
mentioned earlier,
we had some big names there.
And the performance
on those apps
has just been really fantastic.
So for Netflix, for example,
huge 100 million users plus,
they see in the order of
30% or 40% of their users
being signed in
automatically with this.
That's a complete change.
Those users, you
can imagine, are now
reducing by basically
the same proportion all
of their failed login attempts.
So by incorporating a couple
lines of code into your apps,
letting it run
for a little while
to collect the login information
from Android sign-ins,
you're now getting
your users into a state
where they can be signed in
automatically almost half
of the time.
And half of the time
will, ultimately,
be the steady state.
Because when someone sees one
of those save dialogs, we have,
in fact, the majority of
people opt in to save.
So, so long as they
have set up an account,
or have signed in at least once,
they'll get into that state.
And I think, ultimately, where
we see the kind of steady state
balance between
Chrome and Android
being is the majority being
originally saved on Android.
So the idea being that
everyone who logs in on Android
is shown that prompt.
It's a modal dialogue.
Opt-in rates are very good.
And the Android to Android
scenario, of user going
from one device to another--
either getting a new device,
moving between devices,
signing out, restoring the app,
something like that--
is very powerful,
and will be a very common case.
So even if you only do
Android development,
it's worth thinking about this.
But that said, if you
do have a website,
it's worth putting
the two together
so that they can
share credentials.
And in order to do
that, there's a couple
of steps in our
developer documentation.
But the general idea
here is that in order
to ensure the security
of this connection,
you assert ownership of the
website that you've got.
One of the requirements is
that you have an HTTPS site,
just to ensure that
everything that's stored there
or retrieved there can be
securely passed to the user.
The general idea that you
assert ownership over your HTTPS
website.
And then once
you've got that, you
go into the Play
Developer Console,
and basically say that your app
is associated to that website.
And then with that link
made, we can basically
have the credentials
stored in either location,
be available when the
API is called in Chrome,
on the beta channel, or on
Android in the current version
of Play Services.
So that's a pretty
cool experience.
I think that really sums
up what's possible here.
And I think that if you look
at how it's been doing so far,
I think one of the main
points, or the stories that I'd
like to tell, is
that this is not
just an API for
the people who know
what a password manager is.
But in fact, an API
for anybody on Android.
That in reality, with
some of the big apps that
have launched already, we have
over 300 million downloads
of apps enabled with
this API, and we've
had 50 million people
in just a few months
save or retrieve some
kind of login information.
And if you think
about that number,
that's more than any of the
password managers on Android
have ever been downloaded
in the first place.
So this is really
aiming to be the login
solution for everyone.
That it's a state,
or a user experience,
where people don't
even have to think
about password management,
or login management.
They just do whatever
they need to do,
they save that information,
they get in the state
where they never need to see or
manage that information again.
They'll just be signed in.
So available on
Android right now.
If you check out
developers.google.com/identity,
you can see the APIs
and how to implement it,
integrate it into your app.
There's a couple of guides
there about the user experience,
and the places where you
should make these API calls.
Pretty simple.
How to handle the different
corner cases and edge
cases-- things like log-out,
or incorrect stored password.
And if you're really interested
in that, do join us tomorrow.
There's going to be a codelab
session in the morning,
I think it's at 9:30--
little bit early.
But basically, In
a couple of hours,
you'll be able to put
these APIs into your app,
and get a lot of your
users in an experience
where they just don't need to
think about logging in anymore.
And that's really
where we hope to take
all of this in the future-- is
to bring it to all platforms,
and basically make an
experience where you can tap
on assisted sign-in dialog
to create an account,
make it very easy to get signed
up, and then wherever you go,
you don't need to worry
about how to log back in.
That's what we hope
to bring to users.
And I hope you'll
join us tomorrow
to find out how to
put it into your app.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]